changing gun laws however could be a
monumental task one reason many of the
decisions are made on the state level
correspondent Peter Doocy explains how
that works tonight
the streak of states strengthening their
gun laws without Supreme Court
interference continued today when
California lawmakers learned they can
proceed with their proposed 10-day
waiting period to buy guns the second
longest wait in the country federal laws
provide a certain baseline that every
state has to respect but then above that
states are free to vary how they
regulate guns and we have wide diversity
in the United States an overwhelming 77
percent of adults polled by The
Washington Post and ABC News don't think
Congress is doing enough to prevent mass
shootings a majority sixty-two percent
don't think President Trump is doing
enough but when states act faster than
the feds the results are sometimes mixed
a California for instance we have a law
that bans the possession of
high-capacity magazines but according to
law enforcement sources no one has
turned in one of these magazines on a
scorecard tracking the strength of state
laws the Giffords Law Center to Prevent
Gun Violence gives Florida sighted the
horrible parkland school shooting an F
the group concludes that quote
consistently we see a powerful
correlation states with stronger laws
have fewer gun deaths per capita while
states with weaker laws have more gun
deaths over half a dozen states get a's
including maryland where there's a
universal background check for all
handgun and assault weapons purchases or
transfers but Maryland's strong gun laws
didn't stop this Clarksburg high school
student from building an arsenal with an
ar-15 other guns and multiple grenades
police say he also had a list of
grievances if a determined criminal
wants to do harm they do harm and if you
have a state banning a rifle just
because of the way
the rear hand is holds the rifle I mean
that's just ridiculous the White House
says President Trump is open to beefing
up the National instant criminal
background check or NICs but the
administration is just as alarmed by the
FBI's failures when you're able to have
a specific troubled individual that the
community is focused on that law
enforcement is focused on how come
nobody can take action so that's another
area sort of outside the background
check system that we're also looking at
as protests continue and new gun laws
are discussed not all elected officials
are voting based on the emotion of what
happened last week in Florida because in
Florida late this afternoon the state
legislature voted not to pursue a new
ban on assault rifles Bret Peter thank
you